Matt taibi who is a sub stack journalist
a lefty I think he's a self-proclaimed
Progressive he was testifying at uh at
Congress it was on the weapon
weaponization of government and while he
was doing it the IRS showed up at his
house okay I mean you cannot make this
stuff up the scriptwriters aren't even
doing that well here it's just too
obvious so anyway Chris Stewart who's a
republican congressman from Utah uh he
asked treasury secretary Janet Yellen
about that this is a day or two after it
happened about the IRS showing up at a
journalist's house as he is reporting or
as he is testifying about the
weaponization of government take a look
foreign
there's nothing about like her energy
her like just general State that's
hilarious right I mean look I don't know
exactly what that had to do with it why
you would ask Janet Yellen that question
so I'll sort of give her a little bit of
a pass of it seems that she should have
been at least aware of it but but okay
so be it Josh the broader Point here
that they're showing up to the guy's
house he's not under investigation it
sounds like it's possible the government
might have actually owed him a little
bit of money they generally don't show
up to give you cash I mean what is going
on here
so real quick on the Jenny yellow point
in particular you know just looking at
this visual of this woman who is clearly
elderly just saying that she is not
aware of what's going on to me it's
perfect right I mean it just underscores
that we are living in what some
commentators have referred to as a
gerontocracy which is kind of just a an
oligarchy basically of elderly people I
mean 65 and up and I think that exchange
right there with the younger Congressman
kind of the older uh you know treasury
secretary you really kind of saw that
juxtaposition right there but to what
you're asking about Dave I mean look
Chris Stewart there was estimating the
odds would be one in a million I mean
frankly he's probably lowballing it I
would guess probably even lower odds
than that if I had to guess there talk
about just a ridiculous chilling of the
first amendment I mean when Matt taibi
has done is just exposed Bladen
government corruption the government
working hand in hand with the big Tech
oligarchs all the Twitter files you know
I know that you know that Dave very well
but man I I mean I have never heard of
an IRS agent showing up to someone's
home either but to do so so literally
while you are testifying on at the
weaponization committee I mean like you
said I mean like if you were writing
this in Hollywood people would laugh it
off and say dude you're just taking this
a little too far but such is the reality
of what we're dealing with if you'd like
more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell